back here in this country president
Trump invited rank-and-file House
Democrats to lunch today essentially
going over the head of House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi but none of them showed up
it was the president's latest effort to
get Democrats to the table to talk about
the funding for a border barrier or wall
and trying to find an end to the partial
government shutdown he was chief White
House correspondent John Roberts and
what happens now good evening John
bracket evening to you what happens now
is the president will continue to try to
appeal to moderate Democrats on his
calls for money for border security
including building a border barrier but
today an effort to do that failed when
two of the co-chairs of the Blue Dog
Coalition and some other Democrats said
to the president thanks but no thanks
president Trump invited a handful of
Democrats to the White House today along
with an equal number of Republicans to
talk mortar security none of the
Democrats took him up on the offer I
think it's pretty telling this was
supposed to be a bipartisan lunch and
the sheer fact that not a single
Democrat was able to show up is pretty
telling as who wants to negotiate and
who doesn't the lunch reinforce the
White House mantra that President Trump
II is willing to cut a deal but
Democrats only want to obstruct on
Capitol Hill Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer insisted he is willing to
talk anytime anywhere well I'll meet
with him anytime he wants as you know
the last time I spoke with him was when
he walked out threw a temper tantrum and
walked out so we haven't heard from him
since then president Trump trolled the
new House Speaker on Twitter today
writing quote why is Nancy Pelosi
getting paid when people who are working
are not below seat rolled him right back
in a tweet saying stop holding the
paychecks of 800,000 Americans hostage
there is no reason for them to be
suffering right now reopen the
government hashtag Trump's shutdown
Republicans again accused Democrats of
ignoring national security just to stick
it to the president
the question is why have they all of a
sudden flip-flopped
issue and the answer is pretty clear
it's because this is now an idea that
comes from President Trump and the
Democrats clearly don't want to give the
president a victory on this issue the
lingering effect of the shutdown took on
new significance today the Commandant of
the Coast Guard Admiral Carl Schultz
tweeting to his coasties today you will
not be receiving your regularly
scheduled paycheck to the best of my
knowledge this marks the first time in
our nation's history that servicemembers
in a u.s. armed force have not been paid
during a lapse in appropriations with
tax season approaching the Treasury
Department today announced it would call
back more than half of the IRS is work
force later this month without pay to
handle tax refunds but that the agency
may still not be able to fulfill some
key functions while all sides claim they
want to end the shutdown there is no
movement toward compromise I'd like to
see proposals going back and forth every
day Democrats believe they can simply
outweigh President Trump as the shutdown
begins to bite you're not winning the
fight you may be in your own untruth
bubble but you're not winning the fight
everyone knows that we certainly do
president Trump continues our plans at
least to continue to invite over
moderate Democrats to the White House to
try to talk to them about the need for
border security tomorrow he may have
over members of the so-called
problem-solvers caucus we're not sure if
that is going to happen ask today about
the fact that Democrats shunned the
president and did not take him up on his
invitation the House Majority Leader
Steny Hoyer said quote my advice to
members is that if the president invites
you and wants to talk you ought to go
down to the White House breath I need
some problem solvers John Roberts live
in the North Lawn John thanks